ja aber es wird jetzt lars klingbeil von
der spd
es ist jetzt 7 30 und wir waren
eigentlich um 7 uhr verabredet
[Musik]
die neue praktikantin bürger ich bin so
was wie die geräte tun werk der
deutschen comedy szene
ja das tut uns ganz gut ich mache
vielleicht den ein oder anderen bösen
witz heute aber ich denke das ist dann
ist gewohnt in mainz studiert ja es
nichts wird so schön wie die eigentliche
situation in der sie sich gerade so ich
muss jetzt wird's parlament wir haben
jetzt die generaldebatte die kanzlerin
spricht und du fängst du schon mal und
beantwortet also wir kriegen immer so
bürger anfragen per e-mail oder per post
wenn das jeder etwas zum klimaschutz
paket wenn es um eine co2 steuer geht
sollte auch das pferd nicht vergessen
werden die millionen freizeitpferde
stehen auf den weiden und verrichten
ihre notdurft und bringen ungezählt das
nitrat in den boden hat es das hier
zurückgeschreckt sie sprechen vom
freizeitwert lustig denn so nenne ich
meine ehefrau auch manchmal
ich kann mich über meine frau reden sie
wieder weg wenn der anspruch selbst
abgeordnete zu werden dann muss man das
ganze person schreiben sie uns endlich
wieder das ist doch gut
da kann ich meine unterschrift nicht
untersetzt
ich versuche alle zwei wochen irgendwie
mal nur ein format zu machen facebook
live instagram live oder instagram juni
wo alle mit fragen stellen können jetzt
versuch mal so auszusehen als fensters
mega cool wie bist du zur politik
gekommen bis lustig antworten oder als
weißes oder ich sehe einfach bei deinen
sachen ein bisschen problem du hast eine
sehr niedrige gedichtet ja grüßte den
auch immer so nett oder nur weil ich
jetzt dabei den größten schub neulich
mal im fahrstuhl geht die tür auf dem
steht da die beide drin und so da will
man dann gar nicht in den fachschulen
wieder aufgeben
so etwas würde ich nie tun
du musst ja schon ganz schön viel
arbeiten oder das gehört dazu es ist
doch kraft wie viel du erreichen willst
wenn du einer sinnvollen tätigkeit nach
sie traktieren dienstag ist für die
bundestagsfraktion 15 uhr geht's los
meister bis 19 uhr
wie stelle ich mir das vor sowie ein
poetry-slam aber alle verlieren
im moment liegen ja auch für alle spd
fans zuschauen wenn man hier einmal die
fraktion sieht neue 2
im letzten video auch für die spd in
oldenburg die 250 jahre und der schicken
grußbotschaft wer bei uns mitglied ist
kann auch in zukunft viel fortschritt
und zusammenhalt in unserem land sorgen
da muss ich dann richtig drauf setzen
dass die zeit versuchen zu sagen und das
kommt wissen hier mach einfach nur so
als wäre es nicht ein witz und dann
sagen die kurdische produziert kannst
auch was erfinden musste eigentlich okay
und action liebe genossinnen und
genossen herzliche grüße nach euro
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich diesen kerlen kühner ist
so was wie der philipp am tor der spd
januar können wir so stehen was ist
jetzt so wie die entwicklung des
menschen aber ich weiß wir finden das
noch aus im moment ist die pizza meinen
abendessen ich weiß nicht bei dir
wahrscheinlich auch wir quatschen zur
politik ich habe vier jahreszeiten haben
wird ich glaube ich habe ja auch
genommen was sind die vier jahreszeiten
bei der juso dreimal herzen einmal
winter nein da habe ich es immer früher
wir stehen haben anfang der blüte
sozusagen der scandlines auch noch der
war ja auch mal bei den jusos unterwegs
sieg noch besser einfach sehr lange zu
die ist ja ja dann wird die blüte umso
schöner
im gegensatz zum elend in der spd hat
diese arbeitstag wenigstens ein ende
finden hans de schreibt über die heute
show ihr seid die richtigen links
[ __ ] besonders welke die stradivari
unter den arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches flugweg
für ein exklusives geigensolo von oliver
welke
abonnieren sie den kanal